Take a Xanax!
Calm down!
Be cool.
Don't be all...un-cool.
I'm still fabulous.
Gone with the Wind fabulous.
Something crazy about me?
I'm gonna tell you
something crazy about you.
Goodbye, Kyle!
There is no pride here.
Prostitution....****
Look at this water!
We're gonna give them
something to talk about.
Ahhh!
Turn it up!
Who's comin' up here with me?
Here comes the photos.
Go!
Alright.
Ahhhh!
It's a party now!
I'm losing my foil.
Teresa, did you bite into the ball?
I was sucking the ball.
You sucked that ball?
-Yes!
-No.
I did!
Ahhh!
Look at this ass!
I wanna go have phone sex.
Oh my god the sting ray!
Shut the **** up!
I'm teasing!
I'm teasing you!
What is she saying?
She peed her pants.
-Ahhh!
-Oh my god!
Things turn real fast
around these cameras.
Hi, girls!
Hi!
They call her the Ramona coaster
because she is all over the place.
Let's just get to know each other.
Do you want to be a
friend to anyone?
She was like, "I'm not
signing this paper if
you cast my brother and my sister."
No!
I was a little irritated.
By me?
You kinda kicked it off.
Ramona's not my friend.
You're my friend.
So act like it.
I don't give a ****!
You're not a girl's girl!
Why would you say that!
You are so self-absorbed it's crazy.
Oh **** you.
What you're not gonna
do is say **** you to me!
Who the **** do you
think you are, Ramona?
Never go against the family!
This is why I wrote
Money Can't Buy You Class.
I come ready to read or get read.
I thought my friends in
Beverly Hills were dramatic.
Are you talking about me?
Is that how boring you all are?
Thank you Jesus!
You gotta keep a receipt
around these girls!
Teresa said she wasn't biting.
I said the same thing!
Kyle, you licked enough
balls last night.
Let's have someone else win.